hi I'm Fox San Antonio's Jessica Hedley
and I'm Ryan wolf our our greatest
responsibility is to serve our Treasure
Valley communities the El Pas cruus
communities Eastern Iowa communities Mid
Michigan communities the sharing of
biased and false false news has become
all too common on
soci
without in March 2018 millions of people
around the US noticed something strange
local news anchors from all over the
country we're reciting the exact same
script on air word for word we are
extremely proud of the quality balanced
journalism that cbs4 news produces but
we are concerned about trouble
irresponsible our country that's because
all these local news stations are owned
by Sinclair broadcast group and Sinclair
broadcast group had a message they
wanted to propagate to the masses most
people have never heard of this company
before but Sinclair is actually the
second biggest television station
operator in America out of the 600
channels it owns more than 150 are
affiliated to News broadcasters like Fox
ABC CBS and NBC more than 40% of all the
homes in America watch the news on a
Channel owned by Sinclair yes that is
right if you have a message you want the
American public to accept you got to go
to Sinclair broadcast group and during
Co Sinclair said the script was only
there to reinforce their commitment to
reporting the facts and avoiding fake
news but we'll let you be the judge of
Ls and what's scary about all of this is
that it still works what's powerful
about the news is that it has this air
of authority it's kind of like when you
hear medical advice from a doctor
wearing a white coat doctors in all
parts of the country were asked what
cigarette do you smoke doctor once again
the brand named most was camel yes
according to this repeated Nationwide
survey more doctors smoke camels than
any other cigarette you automatically
assume that everything they're saying is
true the same is true with the news when
you wear a decent suit when you sit in
front of a professional looking set with
a signature news sound effect and you
say breaking news breaking news breaking
news breaking news with that very
official signing news anchor voice the
masses will automatically accept
everything that spews out of your mouth
there's no way journalists would be
lying to us right and here's the thing
deep down we all know that it's not just
in Clair news like this I'm sure we've
all noticed that a lot of mainstream
media sound similar these days this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy but why is this the case
why does all the news sound the same and
how do all of these media Outlets
actually come together and decide hey
we're all going to say list next stay
dangerous and this is the coordinated
cartel that is the mainstream
[Music]
media so you're a journalist at one of
the mainstream media Outlets like CNN
Fox or CBS you spent years in school and
college working for a degree you slaved
the way at unpaid internships and
dead-end jobs at companies no one's ever
heard of and now you finally made it to
the big leagues but the climb isn't over
yet at a company like CNN or Fox you
still have to prove yourself but in
order to do that you need to break
really big stories but really big
stories are hard to come by you got to
do some real investigative journalism
you got to work leads get people to go
on record you got to put your life on
the line it's a tough and risky life but
what if I told you that there's an
alternative what if I told you that you
didn't have to do any work at all and
someone would just give you a giant
story to report on well that is where
daddy government comes in some of the
biggest and most legendary journalists
like the people that broke the Watergate
Nixon Scandal uh for example Bob
Woodward they were given these tips by
the FBI this is arri David by the way
he's the founder of upward news a
newsletter that covers everything the
mainstream media doesn't want to cover
when it comes to Politics as a
journalist the best sources are going to
be the FBI CIA and US governments people
that have these leaks and especially in
the intelligence Community they find
these journalists they give them
information that will help boost their
careers in turn the government and the
intelligence agencies get whatever Nar
ative they want out into the public
think about it if you get information
from a random person you know nothing
about you have to spend weeks or even
months making sure their story is true
but an FBI agent a government official
you don't have to break your back
verifying their information the fact
that they're the ones giving you the
information is enough all you have to do
is write the story and say it came from
an anonymous FBI Source or an anonymous
government official and boom your job is
done and you're climbing up the ladder
if the story ends up being true you get
a massive career boost and if it ends up
being fake you can easily brush it off
no one's going to get mad at you see if
a CIA agent comes to you offering
information you are going to publish it
no questions asked because if you don't
publish it they're just going to give it
to any of the other desperate
journalists out there that are also
looking for their big break power
corrupts it's no different for
journalists and especially journalists
that work for the mainstream media as a
journalist your job requires you to have
the best information the intelligence
agencies decide to strategically release
what they need to manipulate the
narrative but why why would the
government be so eager to spell the
beans to
[Music]
journalists this is Joseph elop in the
1950s he was one of the most well-known
political journalist in America and in
1953 he traveled to the Philippines to
cover a local election except he wasn't
asked to go by the newspapers he worked
for he wasn't asked to go by the company
of journalists he worked for no no no
Joseph was sent to the Philippines by
the CIA Joseph alsa was one of more than
400 American journalists who secretly
did work for the CIA between 1952 and
1977 and it was all part of what the CIA
called operation Mockingbird this was at
the height of the Cold War when America
needed all the help it could get on
collecting information on Communist
governments around the world and who
better to collect all this information
than journalists it was the job of
journalists to ask questions and travel
the countries that CIA agents would
never be allowed to enter and so the CIA
started recruiting journalists to do all
sorts of work for them some journalists
worked as middlemen between the CIA and
communist spies others shared their
notebooks with the CIA so the CIA could
decide what they could publish and in
the most extreme cases journalists were
used as fullon CIA operatives they would
sign secrecy pledges and be sent to some
of the most dangerous countries in the
world to recruit and handle foreigners
just like a real agent would in other
cases they would be given fake
information to pass on to foreign
government officials but one of the most
important things the CIA journalists did
was to influence American public opinion
opion think about it this way if the CIA
wanted Americans to think the president
of whatever country was evil and that he
needed to be toppled all the CIA had to
do was leak a story to one of its
journalists and a few weeks later every
American will be reading about how
president X was the most evil communist
on Earth giving the CIA the perfect
excuse to overthrow the governments well
for the past like 60 years in American
history the CIA has been known to All
Around the Globe to manipulate the media
and they do this for political gains in
different countries what they'll do is
they'll actually create media outlets
and the problem with that is it's pretty
obvious what's happening there the
people get rightfully concerned about
the fact that foreign Federal
governments are running the state media
and so they also found that they can do
this domestically in a much easier way
and one of the things that they realize
is we can find journalists we can give
them these leaks we can give them
information that what they want to
report and so you have this working
together the journalist and the
intelligence agencies to disrupt the way
that Americans think intelligence
agencies say this is the narrative they
mainstream media reports on that
narrative along with those journalists
and as a result you have mass
manipulation by intelligence agencies
domestically now when you imagine all of
this you're probably thinking that all
these journalists were just small time
upand cominging journalists desperate
for work but that could not be further
from the truth some of the biggest names
in journalism were in on it we're
talking about Executives and journalists
from The New York Times Newsweek New
York haral Tribune CBS ABC and NBC they
were all happily working for the CIA but
then in 1977 operation Mockingbird was
finally exposed by ex- Washington Post
writer Carl Bernstein so suddenly
secretly using journalists to influence
America just wasn't an option anymore
but the CIA and the US government was
not going to give up that easily so
instead of doing this covertly they were
now just going to do this overtly just
wide in the
[Music]
open back in the day none of these
journalists were saying that they were
working as assets for the intelligence
agencies they weren't doing that but
they were winning Awards and they were
creating a serious impact today it's
much easier because these mainstream
media Outlets CNN NBC CBS what they do
is they'll hire former intelligence
officials that'll be contributors so
when before they kind of really had to
hide and make this kind of influence
covert today it's as obvious as turning
on CNN and look who's talking it's two
different former directors of the CIA or
the director of the FBI and one of the
open Secrets in Washington is that if
you are a former director of any kind of
intelligence agency you are never really
leaving that role and so you might have
that former part of your name but you
are working in loyalty to that
institution you still talk to the people
that are higher ups in there and you
still know what kind of information is
good to get out and which is bad to get
out so is the CIA and intelligence
agency still affecting the mass media
today yes and it's never been more
obvious after operation Mockingbird was
exposed the CIA found a brand new way to
get his narrative out to the public
instead of hiding in the shadows it
would just send all its former directors
and agents to become the media's most
trusted sources once you're part of that
power structure and once you identify
with that class of people you never
really leave it and a great example of
this and this is pretty unprecedented is
Barack Obama is one of the first
presidents to ever decide to stay in DC
after leaving and because he in DC is
able to still know what's going on he
still has a vested interest he still
helps other candidates and plays a role
in politics and so for these people that
were once at the height of their careers
for example imagine the former CIA
director he had been at the Pinnacle of
power in America for them to just have
all of these secrets to understand
everything that's going on and to just
go and retire and some Farm in Montana
it'll never happen once these people are
in the system they're always in the
system and they always want to have a
role in this you wouldn't ever
relinquish power those people don't do
it they know what's going on they are
contributors on these mainstream media
Outlets because they have have skin in
the game they're trying to push a
certain narrative and if they were just
regular people they really wouldn't have
the same kind of incentives to go on CNN
every night and push a certain agenda so
some of the biggest hoaxes that America
in the past couple of years has
witnessed has been a result of these
former intelligence officials going onto
CNN going onto NBC and just talking but
they can also play a defensive role and
so when we remember the hunter Biden
laptop being weaked that initial story a
lot of people at the time were realiz
realizing that this is crazy because for
the first time you have evidence of
Biden family corruption right in the
open and so what the former intelligence
officials did is they went on television
and they went to the journalists and
said here's a list of all of these
intelligence officials that say this is
Russian disinformation there's a
complete fabrication they had no
evidence for it but as a result the
mainstream media reported this is
Russian disinformation and then they got
the social media outlets and the
internet essentially to censor the story
and so they made a really important
story disappear so it can work both ways
this type of influence can be used to
create narratives or to suppress them
but the result is always the same and
it's to protect their own power and we
can assume that this has been happening
as far back as when operation
Mockingbird was exposed Meet the Press
you go on there you say what you think
is the truth or what you know is
actually a lie in many of these cases
but you still say it and the media runs
with it and the people believe it
essentially they are creating consent to
go to war because first they have to
sell the public on it so it's a
clear-cut example of the way that that
kind of consent is created artificially
but what about the stories that aren't
leaked by the ca or governments why did
Lowe's always seem to sound the same as
well well it's because as it turns out
the grooming and conditioning of
mainstream media journalists runs much
deeper than just their
[Music]
sources turn on CNN Fox or NBC and look
at who they get their information from
if it's not a CIA or government official
it's usually an expert in some specific
field it's no secret that the American
educational system was created to
condition people to think and live in a
certain way you can watch our video on
it to learn more so that is why and
ultimately what you have is a whole
entire pipeline that creates these
experts again it's the universities and
they come out all thinking the same
exact thing and also being Again part of
the same class of the people that are
Staffing the government that are
Staffing the biggest corporations in
America that are Staffing the mainstream
media and so they have really this warm
feeling to each other and they're all
being upheld by again the same power
structure since all these experts are
educated in the same system with the
same textbooks and by the same
professors who all believe the same
thing their expert opinions are all
naturally going to sound exactly the
same so that is why all the news that is
based on their opinions is going to
sound exactly the same too and so there
you have it most of the time it's not a
cabal of news people in a dimly lit room
heading down scripts for news anchors to
read like what Sinclair did let's be
real this probably happen sometimes but
most of the time all the news sounds the
same because everyone in the system has
the incentive to push the same narrative
they all benefit so they all play along
from the government to the intelligence
officials to the journalists to the
universities so if this is the case
where can we go to get the truth well
introducing upward news upward news was
created by Ari to solve this exact
problem and that's why they wanted to
sponsor this video upward news is a
daily email that you can sign up for
with the link below that's read by over
300,000 plus Americans who want to stay
informed and get smarter about politics
all what about the propaganda you get
from mainstream media they find the most
important stories simplify them and send
them straight into your inbox every
weekday I love reading upward news
because I constantly learn a ton of
stuff that I don't get anywhere else
like this story about how everyone's
favorite Hub website has profited off of
videos of children being exploited on
their sites a prime example of a story
that you're not going to hear on the
news and I love how quick and easy the
newsletter is too it only takes a few
minutes to read and can't be censored I
cannot recommend them enough so
definitely click the link below and sign
up for the free 30-day trial kind of one
of the big things that we've talked
about is that advertising is a serious
problem for different media Outlets it
always presents a conflicts of interest
regardless of how these media Outlets
want to talk about it so one of the best
ways to get around this is to actually
having people sign up for memberships
when people are supporting your news and
they believe in it and they want you to
be able to report without these kinds of
conflicts of interest it creates an
incentive for you to want to actually
report on the truth it gives you the
leeway and the capability of actually
doing so and so at Upward news that's
the one thing we're trying to do right
now is we're trying to build up our
premium subscriptions because these
people support us they want us to be
able to continue reporting the truth to
them and in return we have a lot of very
good premium content and we have
newsletters that make sure that you can
escape the Daily News cycle you can get
rid of all of the noise and truly know
what's going on in just a couple of
minutes every single day and so the
people that are really most passionate
about being able to walk outside and
understand what is happening in America
rather than endlessly scrolling through
Instagram through social media clicking
through the different channels of their
television those people that just want
to know the truth and don't want that
hassle they become premium subscribers
and they love it so click the link below
or go to join. up. newj trend for your
free 30-day trial now as One Premium
member put it upward is the first paid
new subscription digital or print I've
ever signed up for and I'm wonderfully
pleased y'all do great work thank you
keep it up click the link below to get
started now stay dangerous and we'll see
you in the next
one
[Music]